but i did i saw some old friends and
some uh
parents of old friends and it's just
depressing um we're all getting older
everybody's getting older i mean that's
the only way to say it
um the good times are over
and i don't mean forever and i don't
even mean for the country even though i
you know i've made that case ad nauseum
um i mean for the friendships
that you had um
the golden age is over
um now there is
not much left there's not much left and
that's sad but
there's something nice about there's
something that
you know uh definitive about that where
you can look at
people and go wow because you know
that's where you really appreciate
time when you look at people that you
used to be
really close with and then you pull back
and you see them later on
and you're in a different place and
they're in a different place
and you barely know each other that's
when you start appreciating time you go
wow you know that's uh a mind [ __ ] when
you
when you when you kind of pull back and
you go oh you know i was so tight with
that person
i was so close with that person and uh
now i i you know i'm struggling for
things to say
you know within a few minutes i'm
struggling
for things to say we're making inane
meaningless small talk
and these are people that i used to you
know we used to conversations were
effortless
there was always something to talk about
now they're feeling me out and i gotta
feel them out about how political can it
get and
and everybody knows where i stand on
everything i'm not like a
private person but like it's still weird
when you're when you're in a room with
people they're like well are you really
that guy are you that guy are you this
guy who are you and
they don't know what they can say and
it's odd because these are the people
that you
really you know spent a lot of time with
and you had a very organic and natural
relationship
with these people and then you just
gotta you look at it and go well
that's over you know especially
when you sober up everybody on long
island's still boosting it up
and they don't care i mean they don't
care and god love them god bless them
and i mean people in long island they'll
tell you
they survived a brain aneurysm without
blinking i mean they'll they'll
they'll light up a cigarette and go yeah
they found me on the floor i was
bleeding out
they said it was an aneurysm you know i
don't know pulmonary embolism maybe it
was a
yeah i think i had a few pulmonary
embolisms in my left lung i cough one up
over
uh breakfast and uh and they'll be just
sitting there drinking the vodka and
telling you they'll tell you
they'll tell you right to your face and
you're like oh my god is are you okay is
this okay yeah yeah i'm fine it's okay
don't worry about it
don't worry about it you know just
lighting a butt drink yeah yeah yeah it
was a i had a coronary at a bypass
it was a uh you know all of my heart
valves were clogged uh at maximum and i
uh
i just woke up and they say it so
nonchalantly
and it's everything that's they every
decision they've ever made in their life
is leslie
has led up to that so i get why they say
and i'll probably say one day without
being shocked i'd be like right i just
woke up and i took a breath and i
couldn't breathe and i fell down on my
face
and you'll be telling someone who's not
at that point in their life
and there's something so crazy about the
nonchalant way they just kind of go over
all their health problems and then just
put the butt right back
in their mouth and light it up and then
just start drinking again like nothing
ever happened they'll just tell you they
go yeah i was clinically dead for eight
minutes
yeah clinically dead for eight minutes
and then they brought me back and
i remember the paddles i remember the
cold paddles on my
chest and i remember
there was there was a dark tunnel i was
in a dark tunnel
and i felt like there were these beings
grabbing me and pulling me into hell
ah and then they'll just light up a
cigarette and fall back in their chair
and they're like
but you know i mean things are good all
the tests are good now
and i'm like oh okay well good to see ya
glad i came by hope everyone's well
give my best to everybody
i mean people that stay in the northeast
just get
hit with a shovel there is no way out
a lot of people that leave the northeast
end up for whatever reason
you know extending their life by a few
years not that that's always
preferable but you know i was in the fat
store
dxl in palm desert before i flew to new
york and uh
you know the worst employees of the fat
store ones that try to make it like a
nice experience because
it by its very nature is um
uh a disgraceful
experience you have to try on clothing
and see what makes you look less fat i
mean that's the whole point of the fat
store
how do you look less fat by the clothing
that you put on it's not it's never
what makes you look good it's never that
it's a
lesser of two evils
situation it's voting it's voting in
america
it's there's no real like there's no jfk
moment in the fat store where you grab a
shirt and you're like
this is it there's none of that there's
no hope and change
there's no there is none of that there
is just the harsh
cynical realism of what is available
what will look okay on you what will
look
decent what will not cause people to
vomit when you walk in a room
and what can survive the rinse cycle and
that you won't spend ninety dollars on a
shirt and then pull it out
and then after the rinse cycle it's now
over and i've had those experiences
where you pull the shirt out
of the rinse cycle and you go this is
done i can admit it to myself
or i can deny it i can lay on my bed and
then pull the shirt and i can tuck my
knees under it
and try to stretch it back out okay and
i've done that many times
but we're also gonna have to be honest
sometimes it goes through the washer and
dryer and then that's it
it's a one and done that's a one and
done sometimes
um and i'm in the fat store and i try
not to speak to any of the people that
work there i'm always polite i'm almost
hey
how are you do you have this in this so
you have you know but i'm never like
how's your day
you know and uh see this guy starts
talking to me and he goes well what part
of new york are you from and i'm like
long island you know and he goes oh
that's great he goes you know
he goes you live here now i said yeah i
live here he goes don't you notice
that when you go on facebook like he
goes right into it and i'm like uh
automatically you know already feeling
nauseous i'm like oh boy
he goes oh you notice when you go on
facebook everybody from the northeast
they look shot
and everybody that got out of there they
seem a little happier and i'm like yeah
i gotta be honest you're right about
that
then he goes like this to me he goes he
looks at me goes
did you hear about that actress who got
murdered the other day
and i said what he goes that actress who
got
murdered she's famous reese
he goes she was like stabbed with a
knife because her name's like reese
like reese i'm like reese witherspoon
and he goes no with a knife
and i'm like
what a what a what a life
this guy has just trying to slip that
joke
into every conversation with a fat
person
in the palm desert mall like every every
[ __ ] guy
in there some guys much fatter than me
like buying like five x's and [ __ ]
this guy is just looking for an
opportunity to slip
the reese witherspoon with a knife joke
in there but he was right about the east
coast he was certainly right about that
um and i don't know i mean it's one of
those situations where
you you you love the idea that at some
point you you can you can
you can do you can get you know you can
find
some value in the p like in the
in the in the people that you spent all
those years with and not that they
aren't
tremendously valuable but i mean like
you wanna you wanna be able to talk to
them the way you used to talk to them
it's just impossible
it's impossible you know i don't know
that it has anything to do with my
career or anything like that maybe some
of it does i don't think so
i think it's just because i made it out
i got out
i think i got out and i'm doing okay and
there's there's the people that get out
and then the people that don't get out
and then the people that get out are you
know just
they're out they're on a journey and
then the people that didn't get out
you know kind of look at those people
and they're like yeah
okay sure you know
like you know i said to somebody my
friend's mother i said hey i got a house
palm springs i rented it for a few
months if you ever want to get out of
new york
you come over there and uh you can stay
with me if you want you know she's like
how do you have that
it's like her first you know
i don't know i'm selling drugs like
what's the answer you know
like oh you know the podcast has done
well and everything and
you know again it's just a house with a
few bedrooms it's not you know
this is the hamptons estate just a home
how do you have that and it's like well
there's the warm long island
you know reception i've been i've been
waiting for she looks at me
she goes you guys were the needy
generation
you always wanted things you needed
things i'm like well also but your
generation of parents was also like you
guys were like
the boomer generation of like hey
you were really and it's so funny i love
this woman she's a great lady
but she always wanted to leave new york
like she was always talking about buying
a condo and getting out of new york and
then i asked her i'm like you ever think
about you know get out of here i know
you talked about florida for many years
i mean
and when i say she talked about it i
mean every conversation that
she had when we were young she found a
way to inject it into
uh the conversation that she wanted to
move to florida you know or
or the carolinas or somewhere and i'm
like you ever think about you ever think
about leaving you know now you've
covered in the city and she goes where
am i gonna go
my friends are here i'm like okay
yeah she goes i'm alone i don't want to
go somewhere
now and be a lot you know and i'm like i
understand that's those are all good
reasons
so that's it man that's the thing with
long island you know
no matter how strong the bluff is
nobody's leaving
they're just not going they're not
leaving
i was for sure certain that this lady
would have a place and do like six
months six months
but you get to a certain age where
you're like why am i going to leave
everything that i know because at a
certain age that is all you have
familiarity
is all you have at a certain age because
you're tired
but knowing that you know the people in
the neighborhood you know the stores you
know the restaurants you know the street
signs
you know the stop lights you probably
even know a few of the cops you know the
way
things work you are you know comfortable
and that is what you have that is the
only thing left
and there there's a sadness to that in a
way because we we tend to think of
life being an adventure and it's about
new things and it's about
you know challenging yourself or
whatever and you know i think at a
certain
age all of those things um
uh no longer uh present themselves as
exciting they present themselves as
terrifying
and most people and sometimes that age
is 23
you know sometimes people just settle in
and they just
dig in and they stay where they are and
there's no better example of that than i
know about than you know long island
because the you know a lot of people um
and then some people of course leave
long island and they go be you know
racist in north carolina or something
they
you know it's not the physical it's not
really the physical space some of them
just
you know get out and you know take your
values with them you know it's not
you know it's not exactly necessarily
confined to a geographic location
but it's just funny uh you know and then
you wanna you wanna and you don't know
what you're expecting that's the other
thing when you go back and see people
you you kind of don't know what to
expect
you don't know if they're gonna be like
oh my god it's so great to see you and
give you a hug and you know and now this
covert thing is [ __ ] weird you walk
in you don't know hey can i
do i elbow bump you i'd rather do
nothing
like if i'm not gonna give you a hug can
i just like not do anything
uh do we elbow bump do we fist bump
do i do a black power bump to you
i don't know how do we how do we
navigate
this insanely awkward moment right now
that we're having like walking in having
not seen
you know people for years and then you
know basically
not being able to go up to them and hug
them
um it's [ __ ] weird
every interaction feels like a weird
interview
where you feel like you're interviewing
for a job and it's a job you don't want
and that's every interaction the
majority of them that i've had this week
not all of them we had a lot we had a
cool lunch
um uh with a very smart person but
the the majority of these interactions
that we've had have been
you know kind of awkward stilted
uncomfortable uh interviews where it's
like so how have you been faring
so how have you been have you known
anyone who has died because you're
across a room by the way
so you're not near any once you've got
to be across your woman do you know
anyone who has died from this
or not remember your cousin jenna
yes she's dead now
jenna died you know jenna she had lupus
jenna had lupus she was overweight she
was joe's daughter
i don't know remember she sang at mary's
wedding
did she die of covid they think so
you know it's good to see you
california it's whatever
i mean what are you gonna [ __ ] do you
gotta do these things right you gotta
see these people